[Music]
excuse me say something you want me to
tell you that's what we do here come
along Dorothy you don't want any of
those apples food what the [ __ ] does
that mean it's just that she doesn't
like little green words grandmother
willow I need to talk to you what do you
want my father wants me to marry kocoum
how only thing you should be worried
about it's how you give me a late today
I know let me just ask you a question
you ever get punched in the face we're
talking too much but grandmother willow
answer the [ __ ] question I'm running
through the woods and then right there
in front of me is an arrow you you're
not afraid of the dark I hear you're
dead
you won't tell me why you've paid some
drug trafficker 1015 times in a row it's
talking merry the tree is talking don't
encourage it
I'm from you talking I'd pay to get
punched dead in the [ __ ] face
hey overdose got it
what did you say stop you're looking at
this is bras ooh look again don't make a
move till you're in the groove and do
the Peter Panda dance just hot three
times like a kangaroo besides did it
twice just like the craps to hold your
breath to the left that's the Peter
Panda dance if you do what you might
instinctively do which is breathe in and
hold your breath and then you go out
into the low vacuum of space that air is
gonna be trying to get out it's been a
rough she realized oh no